with 24 million customers across seven
countries sky by any definition is a
massive company but this industry leader
is now pledging to improve its
environmental impact dramatically over
the next decade the media company plans
to go net zero carbon by 2030 to help in
the fight against climate change
launching our ambition to become Net
Zero Carbon by 2030 so we know that the
UK's got a target to become a net zero
by 2050 we want to do that 20 years
early and really be part of the
forefront of that move to a net zero
carbon economy the pledge is hugely
ambitious and will involve cutting
emissions created by people using sky
services like Sky TV it also plans to
reduce emissions in the workplace by
amongst other things improving transport
for its staff eventually Sky's entire
fleet of 5,000 vehicles will be switched
to zero emissions but the biggest target
will be helping the 11,000 companies
that work with Sky in its supply chain
by this Factory in China go net zero
carbon sky is already carbon neutral and
has been since 2006 as it expanded its
main campus in West London it put in
place environmentally friendly
infrastructure but its latest plan goes
far beyond this and it's hoping to
encourage others to follow its lead and
change their environmental behavior
there is no Doubt's environmental
awareness is good for business
activists like Greta tunberg have forced
the issue into public consciousness
companies like Microsoft have already
decided to move with the times it wants
to remove from the environment all the
carbon the companies emitted since its
founding in 1975 environmental experts
say it's good companies are taking the
initiative but the government needs to
do more Sky Microsoft they've all sat
down and they've looked at the science
and they've gone this is scary we need
to do this as quick as possible we can
show leadership and we can do this by
2030 now what I'm hoping is those
companies can show that if they're going
to do it then government has to follow
sky has been campaigning for the
environments for more than a decade
it's Ocean Rescue project exposed the
toxic levels of pollution in the world's
oceans and highlighted the need to pass
on single-use plastic it's hoping its
latest pledge will also inspire others
this time to go zero
Alex Rossi Sky News West London